sur pratique je vous ai trouvé très
sévères vis-à-vis de l'intermittence des
éoliennes
alors parce que moi j'en ai deux cents
et quelques dans mon département qui est
un département rural et où il ya encore
quelques installations qui vont se faire
je le traverse quasiment trois ou quatre
fois par semaine avec une voiture
derrière qui ne peut pas consommer un
litre et demi au sens et je les vois
rarement à l'arrêt alors est ce que je
je passe à des horaires où elle tourne
systématiquement parce qu'elles m'ont vu
arriver ou bien un élément de réponse
chiffres officiels je vais vous donner
un élément de réponse
d'abord comme vous le savez la
production injectée sur le réseau et une
fonction de la du cube de la vitesse
donc entre une vitesse de rotation
données et deux fois la vitesse de
rotation donné la puissance injectée sur
le réseau varient d'un facteur 8
s'il te dire puis si ça tourne deux fois
plus vite ces huit fois plus
d'électricité sur le réseau a donc cessé
le cube de la vitesse du vent docsis et
ça c'est un truc qu'on a du mal à
apprécier avec nos sens et la deuxième
réponse suivant marnais est moins
intéressant que le granville et pas les
besoins non mais alors effectivement
mais ça il faudrait qu'on le fasse
passer au niveau du grand public parce
que on est toujours pareil on est dans
la logique du tout ou rien soit le
tournoi le tournoi mais effectivement si
elles tournent pas vite
il ya le fameux facteur de
démultiplication à un début de réponse à
votre question il ya des physiciens qui
été gratté par cette question qui ont au
terme d'un long travail de fourmi parce
qu'il n'ya pas de centralisation de ce
genre d'info était récupéré les
puissances injectée sur le réseau auprès
de rte qu'il fournit pour la france de
l'exploitant allemand qu'afin de et du
réseau allemand qui fournit pour
l'allemagne en plus en plusieurs
morceaux de l'exploitant espagnol qui
fournissent à pour l'espagne jour par
jour donc il faut faire un travail
extrêmement passionnant de recopie des
trucs dans un fichier excel et voilà ce
que ça donne
entre septembre 2010 et mars 2011 avec
un pas de temps qui est celui de leur si
ma mémoire est bonne donc vous voyez que
en gros ou bien vous avez une dépression
atlantique et toutes les éoliennes
produisent qu'elle soit en espagne en
allemagne en france en uk etc ou bien
vous êtes en régime anticyclonique et
vous avez un peu de vent résiduelles à
gibraltar dans le couloir rhodanien etc
mais vous avez un talon et la puissance
installée là haut donc ce que vous dites
graphique c'est que en moyenne vous
n'êtes sur ces six mois vous n'êtes
jamais à mieux que la moitié de la
puissance installée que la puissance
garantie est une petite fraction de la
puissance installée de l'ordre de
quelques pourcents et vous voyez ici
clairement l'intermittence induites que
vous devez contrebalancée par soit des
barrages soient des centrales à gaz
alors les espagnols ont choisi des
centrales à gaz ge qui est maintenant
l'heure où de bons
en gaz et en co2 donc en même temps
qu'ils installaient 15 mégawatts
d'éolien ils ont installé par dont 20
gigawatts d'éolien ils ont installé 15
mégawatts de centrales à gaz et y
publient des très beaux communiqué de
presse quand c'est l'éolien qui domine
mais enfin il devrait publier trois fois
plus souvent des communiqués de presse
en expliquant que c'est le gaz qui
domine un ba oui exactement ça qu'ils
devraient faire
les allemands ont choisi de compenser ça
avec le charbon et les danois ils ont
fait un truc qui est absolument génial
comme en gros le pays est trop petit
compte tenu de la quantité d'éoliennes
qui là pour absorber sa propre
électricité d'origine éolienne
quand le vent souffle il exporte vers
qui est ce qu'ils exportent vers les
pays avec lesquels il est interconnecté
l'allemagne d'une part et la norvège de
l'autre quant à norvège reçoit de
l'électricité danoise que le danois ne
peut pas fuir il doit s'en débarrasser
c'est pour l'équilibré du réseau
électrique doit absolument s'en
débarrasser que fait danemark à ce
moment il est prêt à vendre à n'importe
quel prix quel est le prix auquel de la
norvège va accepter l'électricité
danoise le coût de production marginale
d'un barrage en fait le coût de
production n'a rien d'un barrage c'est
les 3 minutes d'ouvriers qui sont
nécessaires à ouvrir et fermer le
robinet 00 donc les danois ont
subventionné avec leur argent a eu une
industrie qui va vendre à l'exportation
à un coût marginal nul et quant à eux
ils ont besoin d'électricité parce qu'il
n'y a pas de vent il importe en
provenance du producteur norvégien qui
pend fout là pour le coup leur fait
payer le prix fort puisque c'est
d'électricité de pointe donc le danemark
a bâti un fermi dable et c'est pour ça
qu'ils aillent la bronca au danemark sur
ses subventions à l'éolien qui ont été
abandonnés depuis tout simplement parce
que ça revient à subventionner le dr
danois le producteur norvégien qui
possède les barrages
voilà donc les norvégiens sont ravis et
ils sont tout à fait pour l'électricité
d'origine éolienne tout comme du reste
les vendeurs de gaz si vous faites venir
ici un vendeur de gaz il va vous
expliquer de l'éolien et on sait
absolument génial - copenhague j'étais
allé au meeting de l'international
gaccio yonne où tous comme des tous en
choeur j'étais le seul français dans la
salle je crois et il n'y avait pas un
journaliste dans la salle et tous en
choeur les gaziers disait l'éolien c'est
génial l'éolien c'est génial de les
voilà tous en choeur